now revive and restore has been involved
over the last 10 years on 54 projects
and we've been funding projects in 16
Nations
and those projects are focused on 70
wild species
species don't live in a vacuum they
require healthy ecosystems and those
ecosystems
include people their culture and their
values
now we were really excited when we heard
that there was a project called one
people one Reef
operating in the middle of the Western
Pacific in Micronesia and what excited
us about this project was the fact that
it was trying to combine traditional
knowledge with modern science with
indigenous people
let's hear from my Google Mall
where we're from the Eton of eulipi it's
part of the Yap state in the chain of
what we call the outer islands and it's
basically about a stretch of 99 Islands
in Micronesia
we were very subsistence Community we
depend so much on maybe 90 on our
resources our local resources so we
still grow our own food and with very
little import
I think like many many people many many
Coastline communities we are facing
climate change and that's no surprise to
everybody but definitely not for us we
used to be able to predict certain birds
and certain fish migrate associated with
these weather patterns and those
Associated stars that we call the the
traditional markers now these patterns
have changed quite a bit and we can
depend so much on
untraditional knowledge because it's
changed and so I think that acceptance
of that and that willingness to to seek
further or new information kind of
started earlier on we need to seek more
information because it's moving much
faster than we ever know so it takes
science it takes you know genomics and
and DNA that is now collected too the
way the more accurate count of assessing
The Reef health and the fish count it
takes that kind of Science and knowledge
to be able to help us make a decision on
management
we've seen positive changes in combining
these wisdoms of the West and and
traditional knowledge and coming up with
creative ways to adapt to the first
decline in in some areas I think that
the responsibility now in my mind is to
spread this through the region on low
lines English like us to join the
efforts and see from the 10 years of
data of how we can and we will be able
to to fight some of these fast-changing
decline in our reefs and resources